we're going to be hitting on top of the
wind oh
my goodness why is he smiling hitting
him right in his veneers do your thing
it's right on his nose
what's up bleacher report bryson
dechambeau here here at the wind about
to go up to one more spot it's pretty
cool come check it out so we're gonna
head up to uh into the hotel okay and uh
up to the 60th floor
60th we're gonna do something here that
no one has ever done before okay and i
think you're gonna be excited and
interested in the target that you're
about to hit
[Music]
how are you doing
all right headed up to the 64 rooftop
we'll see you up there
bryson come on out here alrighty
this is kind of insane
i would have never thought i'd ever be
up here in my entire life
[Music]
i'm ripping some bombs off of here oh my
gosh gosh how beautiful is this
oh there he is
why is he smiling
i'm about to hit his face all right
what's the yardage 521 yards wow we're
gonna have you at about 650 feet what's
the slope adjustment down to the target
we have it at 19 degrees with a wind of
about nine and a half miles an hour i
might have that alaska plane right there
okay that's a little little different
than i've ever experienced that is
gone
real short
a little short oh you think
[Music]
all right this is the real deal coming
for you brooks
[Music]
was it hard
this is so much fun
how far short is that
how far short was that one
50 yards to the right right by the water
just just wait guys i'm getting
comfortable still
oh
no just drew a little bit come on ball
just got a chance
this guy chance
20 yards short
i see it okay
[Music]
oh it's so good too gosh darn it
oh
oh it was it hard it's gonna happen
don't worry short and left of the
fairway i know i know i see it
okay really thanks
[Music]
do you think baby do your thing it's
right on his nose it's going right for
him come on
oh
oh my gosh
oh my gosh
two feet short two feet no flute
no excuses
we're doing it right here right now
shot coming
oh
stay on the target baby
[Applause]
i'ma hit another one
that was sick
[Applause]
let's go
all right i just nailed brooks's big
head on top of the wind 500 yards away
now it's time to go beat his butt in the
real match